hallo herzlich willkommen meine tochter
heute gibt es keine torte und auch
nichts süßes ich mache heute das erste
türkische rezept und zwar sind es
gefühlte weintrauben blätter samen mein
rezept ist vegetarier steht gibt es auch
mit hackfleisch und zu den weintrauben
blätter noch
ich habe meines selber gesammelt und
weites jetzt gleich weiterverarbeiten
und die gibt es aber auch schon fertig
abgepackt im supermarkt zu kaufen ich
denke die türkischen läden haben die
alle ich zeige euch jetzt gleich wie ihr
die selbst gepflückten weiter
verarbeitet und zwar müsst ihr sie in
salzwasser blanchieren einfach einfach
einmal kurz eintauchen und wieder
rausnehmen und dem kalten wasser
abschrecken und danach könnte sie ganz
normal wickeln
und jetzt zeige ich euch noch wie man
die füllung herstellt und was ihr dazu
an zutaten benötigt für die füllung
benötigt ihr etwa 350 gramm reis ich war
steht vorher immer mit heißem wasser ab
da braucht ihr eine große zwiebel meine
hat etwa 160 gramm
ihr könnt olivenöl oder geschmacks
beitrages öl nehmen
ihr braucht tomatenmark und etwas
zitronensaft und dann noch salz pfeffer
und ein paar kräuter zuerst schneidet er
jetzt die zwiebeln können
die zwiebel gibt die dann mit etwas
olivenöl in einem topf
wenn die cdu etwas angedünstet sind
kommt da der reis dazu und den etwas mit
dann gebt ihr das tomatenmark mit dazu
und da könnt ihr so viel rein machen wie
es euch dann geschmacklich am besten
schmeckt ich mag es mit ganz vielen
tomatenmark 10 kommt bei mir fast der
ganze bereich
und dann fühlt ihr das mit etwas wasser
auf ich nämlich etwa 300
dann geht ihr den deckel drauf und lass
das bei geringer hitze ein paar minuten
ziehen
sie dürfen nicht vergessen gelegentlich
umzurühren damit nichts anbrennt
wenn der reis die flüssigkeit etwas
aufgezogen hat könnt ihr den herrn
ausschalten dann das sieht noch ein
bisschen nach
dann kommt das salz dazu und pfeffer
dann gehe ich noch etwas paprika mit
dazu
und willi das könnt ihr dann wissen wie
ihr wollt normalerweise kommt da noch
petersilie rein das schmeckt ganz gut da
ich es keine aber wenn ich jetzt
italienische kräuter könnte auch etwas
pfefferminze dazu geben
und wenn ihm dann noch möchtet könnt ihr
noch zitronensaft mitte zu geben
das rundet alles noch etwas und dann
gebt ihr den deckel wieder drauf und
lass das etwas abkühlen wenn die füllung
dann fertig ist dass diese noch etwas
abkühlen sonst brennt ihr euch die
finger später beim aufrollen und beim
aufräumen ist sie etwas geduldig sein
und üben mit der zeit wird es dann immer
besser
am schnellsten geht das gefühl und auch
wollen wenn ihr eure ganze
arbeitsblätter mit den blättern auslegt
und dabei müsst ihr darauf achten dass
hier immer die raue seite nach oben
das blatt hat zwei seiten eine glatte
und eine raus seite und die glatte seite
so später außen zeigen deswegen muss die
raue seite nach oben
je nachdem wie groß erwartet ist kommt
da etwa ein teelöffel füllung drauf
zum aufrollen ziehe ich an handschuhen
an sonst mit die finger orange werden
zum rollen nehmt ihr euch jetzt das
blatt und bringt die füllung etwas in
form und dann schlagt den anfang hier
ein zieht es zurück dass es etwas fest
wird dann kommen die seiten rein und
dann wird aufgerollt
beim nächsten genauso er ist die füllung
in form bringen dann oben einschlagen
und zurückziehen
die seiten einklappen und fest auf
frauen und das macht ihr jetzt mit allen
blättern so
minute dann alle blätter auf gewohnt
habt kommen die noch mal auf dem herren
länder gekauft und dafür lege ich noch
ein paar weintrauben blätter auf den
boden damit die gefühlten nichts
anbrennen
die satire ich mir meistens vorher
außerdem die die etwas lästig sind und
nicht so schön
und dann könnt ihr die anderen legen
wenn ihr beim einsortieren darauf achtet
die gefühlten weintrauben blätter
kreuzförmig anzuordnen
dann ist es raus nehmen auch leichter da
kommt jetzt noch etwas zitronensaft oben
drüber
und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr auch noch
die zitronenschale darüber geben und
dann kommt noch wasser rein und zwar
etwa zwei bis 300 milliliter das ganze
beschreitet dann mit einem teller dann
kommt der deckel obendrauf
dann gebt ihr den topf auf den herbst
und lass es aufkochen und dann bei
geringer hitze etwa 20 minuten köcheln
achtet während dem kochen darauf dass
genug wasser im topf ist sonst
verbrennen euch die gefüllten
weintrauben blätter nach dem kochen
nehmt ihr die gefüllten weintrauben
bitte einfach vorsichtig mit einer zange
raus am besten macht ihr das dann
einzeln dann könnt ihr sie anrichten
somebody gefüllten weintrauben blätterte
könnt ihr heiß oder kalt genießen und am
besten reichte das soetwas joghurt des
rundet das ganze ab
und ihr könnt dann mit servieren falls
ihr noch fragen habe beantworte ich dir
gerne und ansonsten wünsche ich euch
viel spaß beim nachmachen und bis zum
nächsten mal